Today's business school bit...
...is taking a look at the difference between the Chairman of the Board,...
...the CEO, which is the Chief Executive Officer and the President of a company.
Well, first off the Chairman of the Board is not actually a member of the executive team.
He sits on the board of directors and basically represents all the shareholders of a firm.
The CEO is the person who is responsible for setting out the strategic vision of the company.
And finally, the President is the person that has to go out...
...and on a day-to-day basis execute the business plan.
So, in a nutshell, the President reports to the CEO...
...and the CEO has the chairman to answer to.
And that has been today's business school bit.